once these nights went on to make a name
for himself in Hollywood with movies
like white men can't jump
a new jack city he also bought the half
vampire Marvel superhero blade for life
in that hit movie series so once this
knife says more than 70 films on his
resume including 18 as a producer and
now he's released his debut novel a
spiritual thriller called talent of God
a spirit warrior named Talon let's
convince a doctor to help him stop a
powerful demon from creating hell on
earth Wesley Snipes joins us at the
table in the studio good morning good
morning to be here we still remember the
movie white man can't jump this is a
white man he can jump but listen I know
that you've written before I know you've
written movie scripts I know you've
written in college yeah but this is your
first debut novel and when I walked in
the green room he said I am an author
that to writing a supernatural thriller
really what a journey what a journey
very different from writing scripts
writing books I got out a whole lot of
respect for writers it's a little bit
more disciplined it's a little more
isolated and you don't get the same kind
of flexibility with writing characters
and writing scene shots and all of these
things in the in the script like you do
with the book but how did you know you
could do this how did you know well I
didn't I didn't you know I said that
challenges to be a scholar a healer and
a soldier or martial artists so you try
to combine the combination of those
qualities and see where you find
yourself in them test yourself and push
yourself so for me this was another
opportunity to express the divine within
me through my art mm-hmm and are you
still acting am i still acting why of
course I'm still acting because there's
talk about a remake of Blade we'll see
we'll see there's been some discussion
about that you know you know they have a
you're interested aren't you narwhals no
no no it's been it's been well known
that I'm interested I think that we left
we we didn't accomplish exactly what we
could have accomplished and there's a
lot of room to continue to tell that
story but we had a new story here you
know it really it's it's be like C odd
and inexplicable you know I mean it's
supernatural stuff the topic is very
interesting to me that you would choose
that I think what thing are you most
proud of Ben what do you regret most
about this really long gorilla and all
the film that we talked about one thing
that I'm most proud of ah that the
ancestors in the good Lord have blessed
me to have this opportunity to take this
journey that I've grown from it that
I've become more clear on what my
potential is and the relationship with
the divine and how to use those
spiritual insights in my art and in my
craft in my day-to-day life and regret
regrets regrets regrets yes then I
didn't get the role you know didn't get
the chance to dance behind the Queen
Latifah as a backup dancer that's about
started out as a dense dancer in a
musical theatre artist so how do you go
to this to the supernatural because I'm
really fascinated by what you and Ray
Norman have done in this book demons
demons everywhere are demons and it's
when it's scary yes well I grappled with
the question of why do we do the things
that we do what makes us do the things
that we do and why do we do things that
we really don't want to do yeah didn't
want to do and we end up doing that
maybe there are forces that are playing
on us maybe there are forces that are
influencing us and our behavior soul
demons soul vampires that get us into
trouble the character is a woman who's a
female protagonist I like her dr.
Jefferson he's a bad girl power yeah I
watched Beyonce's a video who run the
world and yeah okay well that's clear to
me he's not your girl superwoman didn't
reasonably well
- yes what's these nights good Eddie
your congratulations to you and right on
the buck thank you come to the book
signing later on today at the at Barnes
and Nobles in Tribeca
that's called plug is that one yes it's
called plug movies coming out soon I
know I'm town of God is on sale today oh
man we doing a lot of stuff right now
and this